hello everyone and welcome to a very
nice game from the second round of the
uh
online feed a world corporate
championship this is the first
edition of such an event and if you also
i have a company and you have
employees then you are more than welcome
to enroll them
for the second year which uh it could be
could be a good idea
and this is a clash between the spare
bank uh trade union and
the kindred group that uh carlson is a
part of and it's anton corbel versus
magnus carlsen
uh but the teams cannot have like uh
uh all of uh all the players to be
grandmasters only one player can be
rated over 2500 in the in in the case of
this team it's magnus and the korov and
uh every team
must have one woman player on the team
so let's check it out this is a gla
clash uh from board one and i haven't
still haven't seen uh any of the other
games i didn't even think
uh such names like uh magnus and um
quotable would be playing but it seems
that a lot of very strong players are
playing so we're gonna cover a few games
uh and as the title suggests this one
features um
a most impressive position so without
further ado let's check it out uh
cordoba with the white pieces opens with
d4
we have d5 by magnus c4 uh we have e6
knight the c3 and the c6 going for the
for the semi-slav
we have e3 and knight to f6 so both
players just continuing to develop
pieces
knight to f3 knight beat to d7 and now
queen to c2
uh we have bishop to d6 preparing to
castle and there is one game in the
database where b3 was played but here in
the game
we have uh bishop to d3 and it is
as of move seven that we have a
completely new game
so let's see how the game continued both
players castle we have castles castles
and now
d captures on c4 we have bishop captures
and now queen to e7 developing the
the queen and now black still needs to
develop the light square bishop and
connect rooks with
a3 uh of course the the bishop will get
under attack so you need a square to
retrieve it a6 now uh adding additional
support for b5 because you also want to
play c5 next uh so rook to d1
and now comes up b5 attacking uh uh
quarterback's bishop
butcher back to a2 and now the immediate
c5 and black sold all of his problems
now
uh he strikes in the center with c5
bishop to b7 is coming the rooks are
probably coming
at the c8 and the d8 and black's
development will be complete
so d captures on c5 bishop captures and
now knight to e4 going after carlsen's
bishop on c5 and
uh magnus decides to to to trade knight
for bishop if
anton um seems it's uh
favorable for him so bishop to b7
developing the light square bishop on
this diagonal
and now a quarterback captures on c5 we
have captures captures and the queen to
e2 now the rook is probably coming to c8
so you don't want your queen
uh here on the c file we have knight f
to
uh getting the knight deeper into the
position and now
knights the d4 centralizing the knight
but also
uh leaving your control of the g5 square
so now
korobov can easily get his queen over
there so first he pushes e5
uh kicks the knight back and now knight
to f5
with an attack on the queen but also
queen to g5 now attacking the knight
and also if this knight moves then you
could uh be
getting getting checkmated here as uh
both the bishop and the queen are eyeing
the g2 square and i don't think
if i've mentioned but this is a rapid
game uh both players have 10 minutes on
the clock and they get a two second
increment for each move so uh getting uh
both threats out of the way so just
knight back to g3
now blocking uh and here comes rook8d8
so nicely
developing the rooks uh we have bishop
to d2
of course you don't want to trade here
because then would would have control of
the d file so first
bishop to d2 now you can move the bishop
and then both of your rooks will
be able to to either get to the d file
or
whatever white decides so here knight
captures on d2
grabbing that bishop rook captures and
now again knight
to e4 attacking the rook and the knight
here
and it's a problem if you go for
something like knight captures and
bishop captures yes mate is being
threatened and it seems like f3
uh solves all of your problems but just
bishop captures on f3 and
now you have some serious problems
uh because even though you can capture
with the queen the rook will be hanging
here and
you know not not the way to go so before
deciding on that
first the quarterback decides to grab
the rook we have rook capture 78
rook captures and now rook to c1
preparing rook to c7
and now magnus uh abandons the attack
and has to go back
back to defend the the seventh rank so
knight captures on g3
h captures and the queen to e7 now
guarding the c7 square
we have b4 now you don't no longer have
this annoying b2 pawn and your bishop is
now
excellently placed here g6 by magnus and
rook to c5 preparing to put more
pressure on the central pawn
uh queen to d6 and now uh we have uh
bishop the b3 uh we have queen to d3
offering a queen trade you cannot play a
queen d1 now but you can play queen to
d3 and this is uh where
uh anton decides to trade it seems like
uh
uh it's a favorable uh for magnus
because it seems like queen captures on
d3 is the only move because the bishop
is hanging but not really
here coral both plays bishop captures on
f7 and it does make sense if the king
captures them just rook the c7
check but there is nothing better so
king captures on f7 is played and
rook to c7 check now and of course you
cannot block check because just queen
captures queen and the rook is pinned
you cannot
you cannot capture the queen is just
lost so after rook c7 check came back to
g8 by magnus and now we have a trade
captures captures and of course captures
and now
uh corvo is up upon but magnus grabs the
a3 pawn
and now the material is completely equal
so
rook to a7 not allowing the black rook
to move as this pawn would fall
and uh h5 now we have king to h2 and
then now comes
rook to a4 putting pressure on this pawn
we have
f3 by anton and now e4 magnus either uh
uh wants to get this pawn to be extended
to
to f4 or he wants to trade or he wants
kobo to capture here
horrible decides to capture we have f
captures on e4 and now
rook captures on b4 we have rook
captures on a6
and now king to f7 and it seems like
it's a completely
droishan game and in fact it is but uh
korobov is up upon and uh carlson's king
is a bit more active so let's see how
the game
continues we have rook to b6 putting the
rook behind the pass pawn you should
always do this
and g5 now by magnus with e5 and now
rook to b3 putting pressure on the e3
pawn but you never want to allow white
to capture the b5
pawn so e6 would check king to e7
and now we have e4 uh we have g for by
magnus cutting off the king so the king
will not have to go all the way
all the way around to reach the the game
and that's exactly what korvo does we
have king g1 and now rook to b2 cutting
the king off from
uh accessing the second rank king to f1
and now
uh rook to b4 sorry not rook to b for b4
magnus starts pushing the
the pass pawn king back to g1 and now b3
by magnus we have king to h2
again korobov has to wait and see what
magnus will do and now
rook to b1 uh and here is a very
interesting uh
it's a very interesting position because
now you can see that the king has no
moves uh if
if there were no white pieces on the
board uh it'd be just stalemate and
korobov could in fact
go uh go and try achieve such a thing
for example if korvo plays e5
let's say b2 now yes it's very scary the
pawn is already on b2 but just rook b7
check and
good luck escaping checks now because
after you capture this pawn rook b6
check you capture this pawn and now just
rookie six check if black
captures the rook it's tell me that the
white king has no moves uh this the pawn
pawn covers the h3 square and the rook
uh the entire
back rank so here you'd have to move but
the white rook will happily just
continue checking
rookie for check if king d3 just to rook
e3 check king to c2
not a problem rook c3 check and so on
king d1 rook d3 check and whenever
uh the the black king captures is going
to be a stalemate so this is uh
not a bad moment for corbett to claim
the draw but korvo decides to play rook
to b5 he's still
fighting um for for more than a draw it
would seem
but also it could be that they are just
both extremely low on time as they
were so here king to d6 by magnus
sorry king captures an e6 by magnus and
now rook
captures an h5 by anton and but now it
seems like
uh korobov tried a little bit too much
because this position
is in fact winning for magnus but it's
not
an easy uh move to find so feel free to
pause the video here
uh you know even uh even you know print
screen it or something like that and you
know study it for a week for a month and
then come back to this video and
see if you got it right uh but if you
just wanna you know enjoy the show
that's also possible so really
pause the video and try to find the
winning idea for magnus while i give you
a couple of seconds
so uh for those of you who are able to
do it congratulations on spotting
the brilliant uh rook sorry king to d6
king to d6 is the only move for black
here the problem is
if you play something like b2 then white
just puts the rook behind the pass pawn
and that's it
there's not much you can do here and
white is threatening uh
for example after this uh pawn reaches
the b2 square
black black is threatening after the
pawn reaches the b2 square just
rook h1 czech king captures and then you
promote to a queen
but white will never never allow this
white will just put a rook behind the
pass pawn and that's it and that's where
king the d6 comes in
uh as it it it wins so much tempe for
example now rook to b5
this is best for white putting the rook
behind the pass pawn now
king c6 and already you came from here
to here and while the white king is
still stuck here on h2
uh rook the b8 getting the rook out of
the way now you play king to c5 and now
you want to get your king down the board
and
advance the pass pawn to victory but it
all comes down
uh to one move with e5
king to c4 now e6 white also has a very
impressive pass pawn and now comes uh
rook to e1 the king is now also
defending this pawn
and now white needs to guard this pawn
first white of course we'll throw in
some checks rook to c8 to check
king to d3 rook to d8 checklist taking
to c2 rook the c8
check uh sorry uh rook the c8 to check
uh king to b1
and now that the king finally uh finds
safety here you're gonna have to go back
rook to e8 to defend this pawn
and now we use the simple art of
triangulation to
get to this exact same position but uh
that that it's gonna be white smooth so
we're gonna play king a2
and after one more check let's say
rocate check king b2
again the pawn is hanging so the white
rook has to defend it
and now only one we play king to b1 and
we get the exact same position but now
it's
white's move and now white doesn't
really have a good move if you play e7
uh then of course this is just winning
for us we're going to play b2
and that's it the the white king has no
moves you're going to have to move the
rook somewhere
and wherever you move the rook we just
eliminate this pawn and then it's
winning for us because we have a pass
pawn on b2
so that's what would happen if you push
the pawn but if you don't push the pawn
you try you can play something like rook
to g8
try and maybe grab some of these pawns
just b2 it's not a problem if rook
captures we're just going to play king
to c2 prepare to queen our pawn
and if rook to b4 getting the rook
behind the passport we're just going to
queen our pawn and that's it captures
captures we capture this guy here
once it's our move and then it's just a
completely winning endgame for black
so not an easy move to find and like i
said both of them had only a few seconds
on the clock so they
uh couldn't calculate all
all this way uh but magnus did not go
for uh king 36 magnus in fact played
rook to c1
uh for who i i don't know why
uh but corbo of course immediately just
played rook to b5 he put the rook behind
the pass pawn and now it's not
uh uh no longer possible for the pawn to
be pushed we have rooked the c3 by
magnus
king to g1 we have king to d6 and now
king to f2 bringing the rook into the
game
king to c6 attacking the rook and just
rook to b8 of course
uh korov will remain with his rook on
the b file we have king to c5 and now
a5 the pawn starts marching forward uh
we have king to d5 attacking the pawn
and now just
rook the b5 check king to e6 and now
king to e2
trying to bring the king closer to the
uh to the pawns here we have rook
captures on g3 and now king back to f2
broke back to c3 and now king back to e2
corvo
now very happy with the repetition we
have king to f5 by magnus now again
king f2 we have rooked the c to check
king to g3
and now b2 magnus now gets a nice pawn
here on b2
and now e6 with check getting the
black king away from the defense of the
g4 pawn so king captures and now
we have king captures on g4 and now king
to d6
also possible is just uh rook characters
on g2
sorry also possible is a rook captures
on g2 and after king to f3
rook back to c2 and then king to e4 uh
also possible because the black king is
now completely cut off
from uh reaching the past pawn and the
white will simply not be able to
black will not be able to queen the pawn
so instead after
king captures on g4 we have king to d6
by magnus and now king f3
we have king to c6 attacking the rook
and just rook b8 korobo remains and the
b-file
came to c5 and now g4 now the g
pawn starts marching forward king to c4
we have king to f4
king to c3 and now g5 we have rook to d2
by magnus trying to cut
off the white's rook attack towards the
b pawn
but now king f5 we have rook to d4 and
now only one move
saves korobo from losing the game and
i'm sure you all know what it is
but just in case uh feel free to pause
the video and don't lose this game for
quarterback
while i give you a couple of seconds
so uh for those of you who were able to
do it congratulations on grabbing that
pawn
and for those of you who just want to
enjoy the show it's of course rook
captures on b2 that this is what korobov
played and then of course magnus had to
capture
and now the pass pawn uh is marching
forward and magnus will have to give up
his rook for that pawn
rook to d1 was played g7 now rook to g1
going after the pawn now just king f6 we
have king c3 king f7 preparing g8
and now after king to d4 we have g8
promoting to a queen and here kobo
characters
captures captures and it was in this
position that
the game was drawn uh due to
insufficient material
so really really wild stuff it was a
pretty
uh uh pretty equal game uh all round but
then uh korobov at that moment uh
decided not to go for that e5 move and
he allowed
he allowed magnus to seize victory but
with little time on the clock it was
impossible to do it but
that's why you guys paused the video and
found the victory for magnus
uh so yeah magnus team lost uh
three and a half to half only magnus got
a draw and all the other uh teammates um
uh on his team lost so great victory for
uh for
the spare buck team uh three and a half
to half uh and yeah
we're going to check up on some of uh
some of the other games from this uh
event as it seems like uh there are
there are much more strong players than
i
than i even thought there would be uh so
yeah
that's the game hope you guys enjoyed it
uh i would like to thank uh thought
dreams
uh scott christiansen with gerald and
earth to the book for a contribution to
my channel thank you a lot i really
appreciate it
uh as usual you can check two of my
previous videos here thank you all for
watching and i will see you soon
uh continuing the coverage of the morphe
saga checking up on your wonderful
suggestions and whatever else happens
in the chess world such as this very
nice event here
so thank you all i will see you soon and
have an excellent rest of your day